13 heures je commence à avoir faim et
oui moi aussi
regarde ai-je bien vu on nie pourtant
point belgique regarde fritz est marqué
sur le panneau allez on s'arrête
un agathois
[Musique]
106e et une canette de bière ça y est
pour un millier ses preuves alors
combien de temps
il pourra pas le restaurant joël
restaurant ça coûte relativement cher
et puis on perd même pour une heure une
heure et demie au restaurant qu'une
crayon demain pour un quart d'heure
beaucoup de marchands satire à quoi ça
tu as besoin maintenant
c'est un boulot
est assez tranquille
mais on est indépendant
ce que je recherche donc fait ça dans la
vie
enfin si vous faire tout ça ou
sinon c'est assez difficile c'est tout
l'hiver l'été ça va être problème là
l'hiver difficile déjà qu'elle vous voit
souvent sont des vacanciers et touristes
ici sur son parti nous ciblons général
dans l'année bah sinon moi j'avais
l'autre place que ça se travaille
beaucoup de toronto et leur même ce
match est un art jour et que pommes de
terre non
car ce n est qu à ce vol ces fouilles
sont bonnes personne ne s'est pas des
frites réchauffé ce qui est le meilleur
il est allé derrière avant de presser
oui parce que je suppose et
et à vrai dire ça bouge un petit trou
pour faire la route pour vous c'est un
jeune faciliter également
ultime une économie même pas non c'est
une question de rapidité
[Applaudissements]
bon appétit merci m
[Musique]